اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ليله
الماضيه والصباح اليوم 15 فلسطينيين بينهم
اسيره محرره من الضفه الغربيه والقدس
المحتله وقال نادي الاسير الفلسطينيين
القوات الاحتلال شنت حمله اعتقالات قالت
مدنها رام الله وجنين وقلقيل
كما شملت الاعتقالات شابين فلسطينيين
بمدينه طولكرم وشبا اخر في سلوان في القدس
هي سياق متصل افادت مصادر محليه في مدينه
اريحا بان ثلاثه شبان فلسطينيين اصيبوا
بالرصاص خلال مواجهه مع قوات الاحتلال
التي اقتحمت مخيم عقبه جبر الليله الماضيه
تنضم الينا من رام الله مراسله الجزيره
جيفارا البديري جيفارا مرحبا بك معنا اذا
ما تفاصيل وجديد حمله الاعتقالات
الاسرائيليه هذه التي طالت مدنا عده في
الضفه
صباح الخير محمد وفق تحديث اخير قبل لحظات
لنادر الاسير الفلسطيني ارتفع عدد
المعتقلين ليله امس وفجر هذا اليوم الى 19
معتقلا فلسطينيا بالطبع المعتقلين
المعتقلون تم نقلهم الى مراكز التحقيق
وايضا في تحديث جديد قوات الاحتلال انسحبت
قبل قليل من داخل مدينه طولكرم بعد ان
دخلتها عده عاليات عسكريه اقتحمت عده
احياء اعتقلت خلال هذه الحمله على الاقل
شابين فلسطينيين بالطبع من ضمن
الفلسطينيين الذين تم اعتقالهم ال9 عشر
ايضا ليله امس كان هناك اقتحام لمخيم عقبه
جابر في مدينه اريحا على الاقل هناك 6
اصابات
بالاطراف عدد منهم بيئه رصاصه الحي خلال
اقتحام قوات الاحتلال للمخيم واندلاع
مواجهات بين الشبان الفلسطينيين وقوات
الاحتلال ايضا في بلده كفر دان غربيه جنين
ايضا كان هناك اقتحام لقوات الاحتلال
اندلعت اشتباكات مسلحه ايضا مواجهات بين
جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في عدد من
الشبان الفلسطينيين ادت ايضا الى اصابه
عدد من اشبان بجراح مختلفه اذا يعني
عمليات الاعتقال
والمداهمات والاقتحامات هي لا تتوقف ليله
نهار لكن كانت توقعات ان تكون حملات
الاعتقال هذه الليله اخف وطئه لكنها لم
تكن كذلك وذلك بسبب توجه اليوم اكثر من 87
الف طالب وطالبه الى مقاعد امتحانات
الثانويه العامه في بلده سلوان مثلا عدد
من طلاب احدى المدارس قاموا بارتداء
يعني ملابس عليها صوره زميل لهم وهو
الشهيد وديع ابو رموز الذي استشهد قبل ان
يتمكن من اداء امتحان الثانويه العامه
ايضا على الاقل هناك 29 طالبا من طلاب
الثانويه العامه لن يتمكنوا من تقديم
الامتحانات التي كانوا يستعدون لها طوال
هذا العام بسبب قيام قوات الاحتلال
باعتقالهم خلال فترات متتاليه من هذا
العام وكانت ايضا عدد من المؤسسات
الحقوقيه ووزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه قد اكدت
انه منذ بدايه هذا العام قتلت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي 28 طفلا فلسطينيا
بالطبع اخرهم الرضيع محمد التميمي من قريه
النبي صالح وهو في حضن والده وتم تشييعه
بالامس هذه الجريمه بنظر الفلسطينيين زادت
من التوتر اذن الامور على حالها لا تتغير
ليله نهار ايضا الحركه العالميه للدفاع عن
الاطفال اكدت في رسائل بعثتها الى
المؤسسات الدوليه في صباح هذا اليوم الى
حجم الانتهاكات التي تمارسها قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بحق الاطفال
الفلسطينيين خاصه خلال عمليات المداهمات
والاعتقالات التي تنفذها قوات الاحتلال
التي تصطحب جنود مجدجاجين بالاسلحه وكلاب
بوليسيه جبار المدير من رام الله شكرا